سبنا جورس تحت القصف عندما دخلناها في
ساعات
الصباح تقع البلده على بعد خم كيلومترات
فقط من خط المواجهه بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه على محور زاباروجيا
في ملجا تحت الارض التقينا فريق خدمه
الطوارئ حيث يقيم غرفه عملياته لمتابعه
الاوضاع الانسانيه لمن بقي من سكان
البلده نقدم المساعدات الانسانيه ونتعامل
مع حالات الطوارئ من اخماد الحرائق واعمال
البحث والانقاذ وانتشال الناس من تحت
الانقاذ لا تتوقف نداءات الاستغاثه وينشغل
فريق الطوارئ على مدار الساعه في تقديم
العون لمن
يطلبه نحن ذاهبون لمساعده عمال الكهرباء
سندهم بالاسلاك من اجل اعاده ربط البلده
بالتيار الكهربائي تخلو شوارع يبنا جورس
من المره سوى من قله يخرجون للتنفس او
لشراء
احتياجاتهم اقل من ربع السكان بقوا هنا
والاغلبيه فضلت الرحيل في وسط البلده
التقينا ق للتو احضرت بعض الخضراوات من
حديقه بيتها وعرضتها
للبيع نزرع كل شيء في حديقتنا نريد ان
نبيعه لكن البيع
السي دمرت منازل يبنا جورس ولم تعد مكانا
امنا عيش منذ ان اقتربت المعارك منها يدفع
المدنيون الاوكرانيين القريبون من خط
المواجهه الثمن الاكبر في حرب طالت فصولها
وتعددت جبهتها حرب اصبح فيها مشهد الموت
والدمار جزء من تفاصيل حياتهم
اليوميه لا ماء ولا كهرباء هنا بشكل منتظم
ويضطر السكان الباقون الى التاقلم مع واقع
انساني
مرير الى اين ساذهب ليس لدي ما يكفي من
المال لاستئجار شقه بقيت هنا مع ان الوضع
صعب والقصف لا يتوقف عندما عدنا الى وسط
البلده كانت اول تستعد للذهاب الى منزلنا
فهي تعرف انه مع حلول الظهر سيشتد القصف
الروسي على البلده تقول انها تتمنى ان
تعود عجله الزمن الى الوراء حيث كانت
الحياه هنا وادعه وامنه ياس كرام الجزيره
من بلده ستبن جورس جنوب زبروجيا